Nobody ever set their sights on second place.
Who aspires to be almost remembered?
There's a reason there are no giant foam fingers that say, "We're number three".
No one wants to tell an average joke,...
...make an underwhelming entrance,...
...go out with a whimper.
No one ever stood in front of the mirror with a hairbrush pretending to be the tambourine player.
And there are definitely more kids dressed as Batman than Robin.
We all aspire.
So when we built the new Samsung Galaxy S II, we built it to be the best and brightest,...
...with the most vivid screen out there, on our fastest phone ever.
Because we're Samsung and that's just the way we're wired.
The Samsung Galaxy S II.